I'm on an estradiol hatch for gestural capsules and compounded testosterone.
Should I order a Dutch test?
Well, I am a deferred believer if you're a boy to literally anything. So you're
altering your hormones with these things. I can't understand why a practitioner would give
someone hormones like this without regularly measuring them. It's no different than if you're
getting a thyroid supplementation of a medication you're taking a thyroid medication because you have
primary hypothyroidism or because you have Hashimoto's. There isn't a good doctor on the
planet that isn't retesting those thyroid numbers on a regular basis. Maybe it's only annually if
you've had it fairly well balanced for a decade. But certainly prior to that when they first start
giving you that, they're probably they should be retesting that every three months and doing a full
thyroid panel. Same thing with other hormones, especially when your when a woman's cycle changes
and if she's in metapause, you know, still you have fluctuations in your hypothalamus pituitary
access. You're still making estrogen and progesterone and amrogens in your adrenal glands. You need to
get this tested on a fairly regular basis. Again, our motto is you can't measure it. You can't
improve it. If you're not measuring the status, how do we know we're in the right balance? How do we
know we're doing the right thing? We need to be measuring things. And that's the idea. I just
can't believe that somebody, whoever is prescribing these, they're not demanding that you get
a hormone test. Is the Dutch test a good hormone test to get done? Sure it is. So get a Dutch
complete test done. There's two on a Rupa store. There's Dutch complete and then there's Dutch plus.
You don't need the Dutch plus. The Dutch complete, I think is $300. It's fairly reasonable.
Order that on our store.